[Music]
a woman claims
using semen on the face is the secret to
glowing skin that's not true that's true
very true is that true
speak on the experience how do you think
this [ __ ] look
those are pretty the little sperms get
into the pores and then tighten things
up yep that's actually what happens
that's the bar told me when we first got
together my skin was gonna look really
good and then we did it like all the
time and then it didn't change my skin
at all what are you talking about you
look young
you look so good
it doesn't happen overnight long-term
thing dude no it didn't work i started
breaking out a lot no you gotta do it
like 10 15 years like yeah 10 15 years
cycles of 10 15 years that's minimal
minimum i don't see a difference it just
made my skin we see the difference we
see the difference so this girl kelly
zolansky was first tempted to try using
bodily fluid after she saw a video
online which claimed to contain all
kinds of nutrients and protein that are
good for the skin
so to get our hand to get her hands on
some she who is single texted her male
palette asking if you would help out
what it looks like i agreed to obviously
before depositing some in a tub in her
bathroom oh
you got to put in the mouth first
that's how it there's enzymes in the
mouth salivary enzymes
after the activator and then the girl
goes like this
and then puts it on like um if i asked
you guys as homies right we're home
we've known each other for [ __ ] years
well that's not you so much i still
don't really trust you or not well i'm
the new geo everyone calls me the new
geo okay no i trust them really still
metro and i hit you up and i'm like hey
man like i heard this thing online like
it's i want my skin i'm having shoes can
you guys just bust and like can i just
put it on hey man can i get c man yeah
and would you like and bartenders
i'm single
i mean you can't answer obviously
because you would probably let me know
but no if i had a chick and i was single
i'm gonna check friend [ __ ] yeah i'm
like no you wouldn't i would put it in
your mouth though cause it has to
activate the enzyme
you're not gonna you're not gonna waste
it you know i mean it's a good product
because bart's very
understanding of the science he's like
he's a good guy it doesn't work unless
it's in the mouth first he's a good guy
yeah he's looking the salivary enzyme
it's like a covet test we have to put it
in that thing first and you got to mix
up the solution the question is do you
do you want it to work or not that's
what it is well that's not how i heard
it works okay so no we won't do that but
will you guys give me your semen
no questions asked i would also have to
be single to consider it no if
i would first be like
i would first be like is our um is this
a shady friend because no she's gonna do
oh you yeah i'd just be like [ __ ] it no
questions asked all friends all friends
all friends no guys too if you [ __ ]
ask me yo can i have some [ __ ] i'm like
i've been waiting for this moment
everybody
i could deliver this
to you today it's already sealed
but brandon's gotta apply it to your
face
you guys know brandon's gotta [ __ ]
come on his gloves and punch him
the barbell ones would you would you
would you give your semen or not if a
homegirl you're single and a homegirl
asked for some i feel like
nah i wouldn't cause i feel like what if
she's trying to get pregnant or
something that's a trap that's right
that's how you should be a pro athlete
that's a pro athlete but that's what i
was thinking but he's a pro athlete it's
different yeah they got different he has
premium [ __ ] i have waste will come his
is worth what
he has to watch out yeah my dna is gonna
have a kid that like tells jokes you
know it's not gonna go very high in
[ __ ] athletics my dna is [ __ ] adhd
[ __ ] eczema [ __ ] insanity like
that's why i'm like
it's not pristine if if we were in a [ __ ]
bank you know his is gonna cost a lot of
money this is the top shelf yeah
right undefeated fighter
physically fit yeah
you got undefeated moisturizer mine's
the [ __ ] 99 cent store dude likes and
his is like [ __ ] hermes so it's
different
yeah how does that make you feel man
hearing that does it make you feel good
are you like flattered or are you like
freaked out
i'm like
[Music]
that's whatever best that's the homie
right there i love that i don't know
what the [ __ ] this is he's unrockable
that's a really great opinion about come
you never had to use like uh come
categorization conversations with your
friends and stuff oh come on what kind
of friends you can you keep around
palm springs is weird they don't talk
about that
coachella values are nuts bro they're
wild out there huh
that was too dry it's super sus i think
it's supersized if anybody was like hey
can i get your [ __ ] yeah like what the
[ __ ] that's why she said her scenario is
like a close
it would bother me that like you're
falling for something so dumb
i would be like freaked out by that i'd
be like dude you're [ __ ] scary stupid
i mean i was i was curious about titty
milk
i was so curious about titty milk right
you didn't ask me for anything i know
because i want to drink your [ __ ]
disgusting titty milk but all i'm saying
is pre-workout wait what do you mean you
were curious about tedious because there
was
where everyone was drinking it yeah but
well we've already done that in life
before do you remember the taste yeah do
you but as an adult
all the all the multivitamins in there i
was curious about like [ __ ] the
nutrients the taste all that [ __ ] yeah
but drinking somebody's titty milk is
like sucking on my homies [ __ ] it's
someone else's body i okay brandon what
do you think about that
what's your take on that like whatever
no comment
well this girl kelly mixes the semen
with some moisturizer because it goes
flaky as it dries
26 year olds a lot of [ __ ] goes flaky it
has to become
she said it's a cheap homemade
alternative to expensive brands i keep
it in a jar in the fridge i live alone
so no one will need to see it when
they're making breakfast she's like i
don't want anybody but i'm going to talk
about it publicly
is there a picture is there a picture of
her face actually with proven perfect
skin
better phenomenal it's not better than
curology i'll tell you that she has
great skin yes actually she sold me i'm
gonna start busting on my face all right
let's go give me some cup dude
you got plenty of come from this guy
don't say dudes no but his needs to be
activated with enzymes in this life yeah
his head comes with too many rules the
tongue will suck his own dick
he's just two-step it's too much trouble
no you gotta activate it
he just keeps saying that over and over
again
no i gotta be crazy she sold me yeah her
face is nice she said um
she said he came over used my bathroom i
gave him a jar to put in i put it on my
face let it dry then wash it off i mixed
it with moisturizer because it had a
weird smell he's not the healthiest
person
oh god why does she have to why is she
putting him on the glass he did her a
favor
why does she just breathe out of her
mouth shitty huh but also though she
can't research if this is true or not
i'm sure there's some data out there
that's i mean
people believe in a lot of dumb [ __ ]
then she said the question she shared
this video about her unusual beauty
regime on tick tock where it's picked up
more than 3 million views
she said everybody knows i'm kind of a
crazy person so me asking for that isn't
really a surprise but when i posted on
tick tock i posted it late at night the
next thing my brother sent me a
screenshot of my face and said somebody
just sent this to the group chat i'm in
for work
yo see that's why you don't know what's
going on
see man and she has an ice cream though
she really does so do a lot of people
that never put [ __ ] on their face do i
have nice kid but you've put [ __ ] on your
face for 15 years right oh [ __ ] good
point but what did she look like before
the comp that's true you gotta she's
starting off as a great you know skin
already now imagine she had like really
[ __ ] up skin that's what you need yeah
you need a you need a rescue you can't
do like consistent good looking skin you
got to be someone with [ __ ] up pizza
face
yeah yeah yeah i like before and after
it's like weight loss things like no one
cares if you look good your whole life
she's not inspirational nobody gives a
[ __ ] dude she said she called her friend
said listen i might need some more there
wasn't that much but when i mixed it
with the stuff there was enough for two
days that's it two days every two three
days this guy's gotta bust enough for
her to get her moisturizer in her
bathtub
yeah what a good relationship in a weird
way you guys ever saved your [ __ ] before
definitely not dude
it's so casual like neither now i'm
thinking about it i'm thinking about it
you've come before have you really or
not no i never i i'm curious now i'm
curious how many uh loads i can fill i
actually yeah i'm actually curious too
because oh you know i get bloody noses
you guys are best friends yeah high
school i said like blade knows so much
one time i was like man [ __ ] this
[ __ ] i wonder how much i could
[ __ ] and how much blood i can have so i
was just watching like fast and furious
with the with the solo cup right here
just watching just not not plugging it
up yeah
single
single crochet it got up to like here
you have one before i started
before you had to go to the blood drive
before you woke up in the emergency room
you're like no i'm here to get blood no
this is a donation station sir oh here
take this put it back
dude
hey i got some blood to give
why are you in a solo cup
[Music]
you